all right
everyone i think uh let's get started um
so my name is farito shmukasi and um i'm
a kernel developer
at work from research and today's topic
is uh robust convex optimization
now uh rob just uh finished giving a
talk on
uh you know just the general uh
optimization framework and
you know all the various functions that
we have the one that i'll be talking
about
um specifically is robust convex
optimization
so before we even jump into robust
convex optimization
let's first talk about what is convex
optimization
okay so convicts optimization is uh you
know
a problem there and you have to minimize
a certain function
and it is subject to a certain number of
constraints which are these fis
what makes an optimization problem
convex is that
the all the functions that we're looking
at f naught and all the f i's
are convex and what i mean by convex is
that
it strictly satisfies this inequality
and uh and and when the the when the
functions have these kind of
inequalities
uh the convex optimization can be solved
very efficiently
uh using very specialized uh methods
now uh in our case in uh
language um the way you would solve this
convex optimization problem is you
basically
specify this objective function and then
you can specify
equality constraints which is this first
constraint here and you can
then specify a number of um uh
conic constraints which are given by
this and this you'll notice this little
papa over here
and that kappa indicates what kind of uh
constraint you're dealing with so i have
listed over here
a number of different uh the different
uh uh
cones uh that we support so you could
have
non-negative cones norm phones
semi-definite exponential dual
exponential
power and dual power cones and so if you
can if you can formulate
your constraints into a form that
into one of these forms over here and
give it to
uh convex optimization we it will
happily be able to solve that for you
okay so now that we have quickly gone
over
convict optimization um what is
robust convex optimization well it's
it's a slight variation from
convex optimization in that you end up
having these
um parameters i'm going to use the word
parameters a little
loosely here because technically there
are uncertainties here
but you have these parameters theta and
this
and and the constraints and and the
objective
are um dependent on these constraints on
these
uncertainties and these uncertainties
themselves
are subject to certain convex constraint
which are these gi
and when you have a problem of this form
then we
call such a problem as robust convex
optimization
so um the best way to understand this is
to
directly jump into a simple example to
get an idea of
um you know what exactly is it
when we talk about robust what is what
is what does robust actually mean
so let's start with um as a simple
linear optimization problem
you know you have bounds on x and you
have bounds on y
now if you solve this without any
thing without any without any
uncertainties in there
then you get a result pretty standard
stuff
now what if your upper bound
uh on on your x and y are
uncertain meaning that you don't
actually know that it's
going to be one it could be 1.1 it could
be 0.9 it could be 0.8
you just don't know so that so when when
such an uncertainty exists
the result that you get this one one
reserve that you get may or may not be
feasible
depending upon what your uncertainty is
for example if this was point nine
then this one one would is actually
infeasible it's outside the domain so
your
so so that so so this one one is no
longer
a valid solution so how does one take
these into account these uncertainties
into accounts so
let's let's uh step through the uh a
basic process of how we how we would go
about doing that
so if so now we have established that
okay our upper bounds have some kind of
an uncertainty so we'll call that
uncertainty delta y
and we'll give will give some constraint
on that
uncertainty so in this case it's going
to vary from negative 0.1 to 0.1
okay now the objective for us is to find
a
optimal solution so that no matter what
value of delta x and delta y are taken
within these uh bounds you should the
solution will always remain feasible
okay so one approach would be well let's
just
sample delta x from this constraint and
delta y from this constraint and just
generate a new set of bloated set of
constraints and then put that into
convex optimization
and solve it and there's nothing wrong
with this approach
you get a result in this case uh it
comes back
and giving you the the the expected
result of 0.9.9
but the approach is horribly inefficient
and
you're not guaranteed to get the optimal
solution uh
all the time so there there has to be a
better
way to tackle these kind of
uncertainties
well one approach would be or a more
efficient approach would be
well find out what is the worst possible
value this delta x can take and this
delta y can take
um and and you can do that very simply
by just minimizing over the constraints
at least for this particular example and
it and it says that okay the for the
worst possible case you need
negative 0.1 as your uh as your
variation and delta y should also be
negative point one
so when you substitute that into your
convex optimization problem
you end up with 0.9.9 which is
sort of intuitive and it's for this
particular example it's almost obvious
so this was your original let me just
make this a little bigger
so this was your original uh uh problem
without the uncertainty now when the
uncertainty is taken into account
you end up having this uh your your new
solution is red is is this uh
represented by this red dot
so this red dot means that means that no
matter what values of delta x delta y
you took
this solution will always be valid so
that's that's what we mean when we talk
about robust
okay so now the question is all right
now that we have manually done this
one example and it's almost sort of
intuitive well
how do we do this in a more general way
and i'd like to talk about that
uh in the in the in the coming minutes
so let's take a slightly more involved
example notice i'm not going to talk
there's no we're not going to concern
also the objective here we're just going
to talk about the constraint and the
uncertainty associated with it
so in this case we end up having a norm
uncertainty so you have
uh this delta x and delta y as your
uncertainty but those
cons but those uncertainties are bound
by this norm constraint
okay so if i were to now i can take all
sorts of extreme
uh regions and i can generate
a feasible region this is you know just
based on trial and error but
it turns out that this green part is the
feasible region and
all these other uh uh other
regions that you're seeing are one
extreme or the other but then but an
intersection of all of them
will give you the actual um actual
feasible region
okay so now how do we how do we
formulate this problem
so remember what we want to do is
generate what is called as a robust
counterpart meaning that we want to be
able to convert
our original uncertain problem into
something that can be solved by
within the convex optimization framework
okay
so in this case you know you can you can
rewrite your constraint
this this constraint of one delta x
delta y
you can split that out and uh and have
the x plus y here
and the uncertainties grouped together
okay and for this particular case
the way you want to uh i want to figure
out what your robust counterpart is
is by maximizing this
term which is the left-hand side term
over
your normal constraint for uh non-coin
constraint
and it turns out that when you when you
maximize it
you that this maximization problem is
equivalent to this uh
this norm of x square of x and y
and you can see that very easily by just
doing max value of that uncertainty
and it says that it's half square root
of x squared plus y squared which is
and and this constraint is actually
a second order norm constraint so if i
if i
plug that into our convex optimization
and now i have a norm of x y and uh you
know the right hand side is just
two times this and when you evaluate it
you get a result and when you plot it
against oops
and if i were to plot it
it shows up right there okay and which
is which is the correct solution so
the what i'm trying to show you here is
this is
this is sort of the the underlying
methodology
that is used in order to generate the
robust counterpart
or aka the a new problem that solves the
original uncertain problem
okay now obviously it would be silly for
us to have to do that every single time
it is it would be more uh efficient if
the whole thing was
wrapped up and could be done
conveniently within a function so for
that
for that very reason we have this new
function called robust convex
optimization
it takes in an objective and then it
takes in those uncertainty parameters
and you give them give the parameter
constraints associated with it
and how and and the corresponding
variable constraints
okay so the exact same problem that we
just looked at
instead of going through all the
maximization and all that we are going
to say that these are my uncertainty
delta x delta y
this is the norm uh uncertainty
constraint and this is this is my
variable constraint
and you solve that and you get the
result it's the exact same result as
before
and if i were to plot it it's the same
result
okay now we talked about tractability
and we talked about robust
counterpart the thing is that it's
not a given that you know any
combination of constraint
and parameter constraints are going to
give you a solution
they're actually you only have very
limited number of cases that you can
actually use
uh or formulate your problem as in order
to
for it to be able to be tractable and we
get a robust counterpart for it
and i've listed here um you know the the
the combinations that make
uh getting a closed form tractable
counterpart possible
okay i won't go through them it's just
there for you for you to
know that this is not like uh the only
case that
that is pretty general is that when you
have um
you know linear uh non linear
inequalities
and in such cases you can your parameter
constraints can be
just about anything any convex cone and
it will work
everything else has very strict
constraint uh restrictions
okay so um robust optimization
the thing uh think about it is that it
looks like you know you could you could
put some simple
constraints together but in reality if
you look at uh
look at the actual um uh the actual
setup um there is the uncertainty space
that you have
can be can be extremely complicated and
so in this case even though
alpha and beta are my uncertainties and
they're constrained by this norm
alpha and beta can take uh infinite
number of values
uh that will still satisfy this and so
trying to get a result
using the previous approach wherein
we'll just enumerate as many alpha and
beta
instances as possible and just give it
to uh convex optimization is not a good
idea
and so that's so it's better to allow
robust convex optimization to do that
for you
okay so moving on what if the problem is
not tractable which is which is the next
obvious question and uh here's an
example wherein the problem is not
going to be tractable and in such cases
you know
it goes through the steps and it figures
uh internally it figures out there's
nothing we can do about it
but all hope is not lost we can still
get some kind of a result
uh using uh some approximations and we
have couple of methods one is called
polyhedral approximation
which basically takes your norm
constraint and converts it into linear
constraints
and when it does that it opens up the
opens up
your possibility of solving the robust
problem the other is the cutting set
method
cutting set method is extremely general
it doesn't make any assumptions so
it works the problem is that cutting set
method and polyethyl approximation
they're rather expensive methods so uh
if
if you're using it be aware that you
know there will be significant overhead
and in this case for this particular
example you'll notice that the results
that you're getting
uh in the x are close enough close
but the why it's not um and if i were to
plot it
they are close to each other but the
robust uh the polyhedral approximation
does a worse job because it's actually
approximating normal
so there will be some inherent error in
the cutting set doesn't make any
much assumptions so its result is much
more accurate so that's what
that's what we are showing
okay so moving on
so with all this hype about robustness
robust optimization
why do we even care why do we need can't
we just get rid of uncertainties
or make some approximations and just go
on a longer happy way
so to convince you that that's not
always going to be the case
i'm going to take this one specific
example so you have two drugs
that a company has to manufacture and
they want to maximize their profit
and in order to manufacture these two
drugs they need to
get a couple of active agents from these
raw materials r1 and r2
so um i'm not going to go through each
one of these in detail there are a bunch
of constraints associated with them
you have revenue constraints storage you
have manpower equipment
budget product you have all these
various constraints associated with it
so i'm going to go ahead and evaluate
this now the
the tricky part here or the interesting
part rather is that
each one of these raw materials r1 and
r2 the amount of active agent that you
can
extract from that is uncertain so there
is this uncertainty associated with it
so it could be plus or minus this really
small amount or for the wrong
second raw material it could be you can
extract point zero two
uh grams per kg but it can also vary
okay and what happens when you take
these uncertainties into account that's
that's the main question that i want to
address here okay so we're going to
put our active agent constraints in
there and uh use robust convex
optimization
to figure out oops
firstly something here
the total cost is missing so give me
just one second
total cost is
operational costs i got
something wrong here but okay
let's try that again and there you go
that's that's your result
right so it says uh based on robust
optimization
manufacture only drug one and uh buy 877
units
um of raw material one to produce drug
one
and when you follow that advice you end
up getting a profit of
around 8 300. okay now
what if you didn't take those
uncertainty into account
which is you know you basically say i
don't care about fluctuation
and in such a case it says okay
manufacturer
still manufactured drug one but now
purchase only drug uh the broadband
second raw material and without uh this
uncertainty constraint
your profit actually goes up which is a
good thing
but what happens when in actual real
life because uh you're
you start doing the extraction of the
wrong uh
of the active agent and things are not
working out as in as in the ideal
circumstance
so to analyze that let's uh let's uh
put it into a parametric convex
optimization
and provide it with the result that we
got from
um the nominal case okay in which case
it said
uh um uh you know use only raw material
too
and you know the worst case scenario is
that we won't be able to extract
uh all of it in such a case your profit
can actually decrease by 21
on the other hand if you used uh the
robust solution
and uh purchased only raw material one
with 877
units then you would even in the worst
case scenario
you would get a loss of only six percent
okay so you can clearly see that just
based on
um these kind of decision if you end up
getting a
bad batch of your raw material due
you your company could end up losing 21
of their profit
but if you use the robust solution
you're at least assured that
the worst you can do is six percent okay
so just to hammer that point home
if you if you look at the graph here you
know this is the ideal case the
very top one and if the active agent
ended up being really bad then
you know you get a slow decline of
profit and in the worst case you end up
getting a 21
decline but with the robust result no
matter what happens
you'll always get a six percent uh uh at
most a six percent decrease in profit
okay so i hope i've i've made a case for
robust convicts optimization here
um let's look at a geometry based
example
um this is uh typically you wouldn't
think that this would be uh in the realm
of robust optimization but this
this is a creative way of looking at it
now imagine that you have
a bunch of circles of various rad
different radius and you want to find
the
smallest circle that encompasses all
these
small sub-circles so let's uh
these are our um random centers and each
one of the centers is
associated with the random radius so
we're going to
um put uncertainty um variables
uh which are which we'll define here and
the the we will redefine the problem as
saying that
in we'll define the subcircles as a
point
which is uncertain in its position and
the uncertainty its position is defined
by the the circle itself which is which
can be described as a norm constraint
so you have uncertainty in your centers
and then
you say that okay um you know the my the
position uncertainty
is governed by the by by this
equation of a circle so let's do that
we uh construct our constraints oops
a little too quickly i just wanted to
show you what the constraints would look
like
so there are a whole bunch of these
constraints you have your so your
objective is to find
you know the the encompassing circle
center and the radius
and you have all these constraints
associated with it
okay you send that off to robust convex
optimization
and it should give a result in a few
seconds
and there it is and when you plot it
those are your different circles which
we have treated for this particular
example
as a point with different uh with the
varying uncertainty
and it gives us the bounding circle for
these
for these cases now you can make this
even more general
you can make these circles as ellipsoids
you can you can do combination
of ellipsoids circles and box
constraints
i mean it's just uh use your imagination
and you should be able to
reformulate this geometry problem into a
robust uh
problem okay um i think i might be a
little ahead of time
um and so what i have for you here
is a number of references if you're new
to robust uh
of optimization um it is it is a fairly
specialized topic
and uh and and uh you know the the
pioneers of this work
are uh you know bental namarovsky boyd
um uh so so you'd be so so the first
reference
that is actually the standard book that
they have written on this topic
and there are a number of other links
that i've also put together if you want
to get a
course or refresh your course on how to
how to
uh you know look at robust optimization
problems and what it means
okay looks like i have we have a few
minutes here so why don't
i take some questions here
um okay so
so boris asked a question is it possible
to combine
optimization with the solve function
family
i don't see why not um you might have to
wrap it around that other function so
that you know the interplay
would work but i i i don't see why you
couldn't use that
um i'm trying to think of an example but
uh
but right off the bat my instinct says
that it should be possible
um jose your question is is there a
statistical characterization
of the uncertainties or is that not the
kind
not in this uh kind of optimization
problem well
there is a statistical conform at least
for this robust optimization the
problems that we are looking at here
they don't uh have a statistical
characterization but there are
um there are these things called as
chance constraints which have uh
probabilistic measures associated with
them
and that that is actually on our
immediate to-do list so
uh once that is in then i think your
your question becomes more relevant
okay um any other questions
well um uh if you have any other
questions you know just
ping me if uh uh if you don't have my
email
which i have forgotten uh to put over
here at spydosham at wolfram.com
right um drop me an email and uh yeah
we'll i'd be happy to answer any of the
questions we also have
an optimization meetup coming up at 3 30
uh
to 5 when rob myself and nina are going
to be
there so um yeah if you have any
questions we can
we talk about it there as well um all
right
well looks like i'm ahead of schedule
here so
um yeah nina's talk is right after me so
please uh please make sure to attend
that one that's going to talk about
various solvers and all the cool stuff
that she's been doing with the
plug-in method so all right guys thanks
again for attending
uh see you guys around
you